The way that I always heard the story was that Van Halen had something in the contract that they used when they toured that said that everywhere that they went-- in every city, in every dressing room on their tour-- there had to be a bowl of M&Ms, and that the brown M&Ms had to be removed. It's kind of a well-known story, I think. And the way that I understood it is that it showed what divas rock stars could be, that any whim that they had would have to be met, no matter how petty. You hate brown M&Ms? Poof, they will cease to exist in your world.
我一直听到的版本是这样的：范·海伦乐队（Van Halen）在巡演合同中有一项规定，要求无论他们去到哪里——每一个城市、每一间后台更衣室——都必须准备一碗M&M豆，而且必须把棕色的挑出来。我想这是一个很有名的故事。我当时理解的意思是，这显示了摇滚明星有多么“大牌”，不管他们有什么突发奇想，哪怕再琐碎，也必须得到满足。你讨厌棕色M&M豆？砰，它们就得从你的世界里消失。
And then a couple of years ago we had this band, They Might Be Giants, on our radio show. And by the way, you're listening to This American Life from WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. Anyway, we had this band on the show. And I got to know them a little bit. And I had never talked to a touring rock musician about that story. And I remember John Flansburgh saying to me, no, no, no, no, no. I had the meaning of the story totally wrong.
几年前，我们的广播节目请到了“他们可能是巨人”（They Might Be Giants）乐队。顺便说一句，你们正在收听的是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。总之，我们请了这支乐队上节目。我和他们稍微熟悉了一些，但我从没跟巡演的摇滚乐手聊过那个故事。我记得约翰·弗兰斯堡（John Flansburgh）对我说：不，不，不，不，不，你对这个故事的理解完全错了。
I think there was only one no, Ira.
我觉得当时只有一个“不”，艾拉。
This is John. I asked him to come and talk about this with me again today, here on the radio. He told me that the music industry name for what we were discussing was the contract rider.
这是约翰。今天我请他再次来到电台和我谈论这件事。他告诉我，音乐行业对我们所讨论内容的专业称呼是“演出合同附加条款”（contract rider）。
The thing that the average rock fan doesn't realize is that in the itinerant life of somebody in a rock band, they're relying on a promoter-- probably a different promoter every day-- to give them everything. And a contract rider is, basically, the entire show from beginning to end. I mean, you're talking about personnel. You're talking about the PA. So a lot of it is very prosaic stuff. People really focus on the dressing room stuff. But actually most of it is just making sure that there's, literally, enough electricity in the venue so that the show doesn't end after 10 minutes.
普通摇滚乐迷不了解的是，过着流浪生活的摇滚乐队，他们必须依赖推广商——可能每天面对的推广商都不一样——为他们提供一切。而“演出合同附加条款”本质上就是一场演出从头到尾的全部内容。我是说，你得考虑工作人员，考虑扩音设备。所以很多内容都是非常枯燥的琐事。人们确实只关注更衣室里的东西，但实际上，大部分内容只是为了确保场地里确实有足够的电力，不至于让演出在10分钟后就中断。
And this, Flansburgh says, was what was so ingenious about the brown M&Ms. Van Halen had this huge setup with lots of gear. And if the local promoter didn't carefully read the contract rider, stuff could collapse. It could be dangerous. So the brown M&Ms were like the canary in the coal mine. The contract rider said that brown M&Ms were not supposed to be there. If they were there, look out.
弗兰斯堡说，这就是棕色M&M豆条款天才的地方。范·海伦乐队有一套非常庞大的设备装备。如果当地推广商没有仔细阅读合同附加条款，设备可能会倒塌，那会很危险。所以棕色M&M豆就像矿井里的金丝雀。合同条款规定不准出现棕色M&M豆。如果出现了，那就得小心了。
It was a very clever way to make sure that all the specifics of his contract rider were going to be met, including technical requirements, safety requirements, all the things that David Lee Roth is probably more worried about than his actual M&Ms needs.
这是一种非常巧妙的方法，用来确保他合同中的所有细节都能被满足，包括技术要求、安全要求，以及所有那些大卫·李·罗斯（David Lee Roth）可能比他个人的M&M豆需求更关心的事情。
Yeah, actually in his autobiography he writes this. I found this on snopes.com. He explains the M&Ms this way. David Lee Roth writes, "Van Halen was the first band to take huge productions into third level markets."
是的，实际上他在自传里写到了这一点。我在snopes.com上找到了。他这样解释M&M豆的问题。大卫·李·罗斯写道：“范·海伦是第一支将庞大制作带入三级市场的乐队。”
Tertiary markets is the word we use.
我们把那种地方称为三级市场（Tertiary markets）。
Tertiary markets. "We'd pull up with nine 18-wheeler trucks full of gear in places where the standard was three trucks max. And there were many, many technical errors, whether it was the girders couldn't support the weight, or the flooring would sink in, or the doors weren't big enough to move the gear through. The contract rider read like a version of the Chinese yellow pages, because there was so much equipment, and so many human beings to make it function. So just as a little test, in Article number 126 in the middle of nowhere was, quote, 'there will be no brown M&Ms in the backstage area upon pain of forfeiture of the show with full compensation,' end quote."
三级市场。“我们会开着九辆装满设备的大卡车进入那些标准只有三辆卡车的地方。那时会出现很多很多技术错误，要么是梁柱支撑不住重量，要么是地板下陷，或者门不够大，设备搬不进去。合同条款读起来就像中文黄页，因为设备太多，需要操作的人员也太多。所以作为一个小测试，在第126条里，在那些不起眼的地方写着：‘后台区域严禁出现棕色M&M豆，否则演出取消并需支付全额赔偿’。”
So he writes, "When I would walk backstage, if I saw a brown M&M in that bowl, well, line check the entire production. Guaranteed you're going to arrive at a technical error. They didn't read the contract. Guaranteed you'd run into a problem. Sometimes it would threaten to destroy the whole show. Sometimes, literally, life threatening."
所以他写道：“当我走到后台，如果我在碗里看到一颗棕色M&M豆，好吧，那就检查整场制作吧。保证你会发现技术错误。他们没读合同。保证你会遇到麻烦。有时这甚至威胁到整场演出，有时甚至直接危及生命。”
Wow.
哇。
Now when I e-mailed you to see if you wanted to come on the radio and talk about this, you said, oh, that's really a coincidence. Because you had just spent your whole day yesterday working on your contract rider?
刚才我发邮件问你想不想来电台谈谈这个时，你说那真是太巧了，因为你昨天整整一天都在写你们的合同附加条款？
Yeah, we're going out on tour for two months in the fall. And basically a couple of days ago, I was looking at the contract rider, which was 25 pages long, this crazy, Frankenstein document that-- there was some really odd vestigial stuff. I actually found we have all these personnel requirements for loaders, and electricians, and fly riggers, and all these people. There are 30 people that the promoter is going to hire on our behalf. And they have very specific job descriptions. But in only half of them did we require that they be sober.
是的，我们秋天要进行为期两个月的巡演。基本上几天前，我正在查看那份25页长的合同附加条款，这简直是一份疯狂的科学怪人文件，里面有一些非常奇怪的残余内容。我竟然发现我们对装卸工、电工、索具工和所有这些人员都有要求，推广商要代我们雇佣30个人。他们有非常具体的工作描述。但其中只有一半人，我们要求他们必须保持清醒。
Wait, your contract for some of them says specifically they have to be sober?
等等，你们的合同里有一些人明确要求必须保持清醒？
It was such a hodge-podge that in some cases-- what had happened is we had had a bunch of loaders that had come in from another show the night before that had ended at 5:00 in the morning. And they came into our show at 7:00 in the morning to, literally, do another show. And they all got drunk in the couple of hours in between. So in our contract rider we said, the loaders have to be sober. But unfortunately, the way a contract reads, it looks like you're kind of implying that everybody else can be drunk. And no one had ever thought to cross it out.
这简直是大杂烩。有些情况下，之前一场演出结束时已经是凌晨5点了，第二天早上7点，那些装卸工又来做我们的演出。他们在中间的那几个小时里全都喝醉了。所以我们在合同条款里写了：装卸工必须清醒。但不幸的是，合同的读法让它听起来好像是在暗示其他人可以喝醉。而之前从没有人想过要把这一条删掉。
Is there an M&Ms clause in your contract?
你们的合同里有M&M豆条款吗？
It's such a personal thing. It's like asking somebody what's in their medicine chest. There are no M&Ms on our-- We have like hummus, and tabbouleh, and like a lot-- I mean, you would think it was Sarah McLachlan the way our contract rider reads.
这太私密了。就像问别人的药箱里有什么一样。我们的合同里没有M&M豆……我们有鹰嘴豆泥、塔布勒色拉之类的……我的意思是，如果你读我们的合同附加条款，你会觉得那是莎拉·麦克拉克兰（Sarah McLachlan）的合同。
I mean more is there an M&Ms clause, is there a thing in your contract that you put in there to be sure that people read the contract?
我是说，你们合同里有没有为了确保对方阅读合同而设置的条款，类似于M&M豆条款那样的东西？
I think the first line of our contract is, "The promoter needs to call our tour manager when he gets this rider." That's basically-- just getting good communication going-- rather than bullying and threshold tests-- is the way we do it.
我想我们合同的第一行是：“推广商收到此条款后需要致电我们的巡演经理。”基本上，就是通过建立良好的沟通，而不是靠欺凌和阈值测试，这就是我们的方式。
And so if you don't get the call you know, all right.
如果他们没打电话，你就知道……好吧。
Yeah. And believe it or not, oftentimes they don't call. They've got other things to do.
是的，信不信由你，他们经常不打电话。他们还有其他事情要忙。
Well today on our radio show we have stories of the fine print. We dive into the fine print, in places where the fine print really, really matters. Act one of our show, Side Effects May Include-- Nancy Updike has the story of fine print happening at a place you might never suspect it. Act two, Occupancy May Be Revoked Without Notice. In that story, David Rakoff brings us the fine print that could fix what therapy fails to. Act three, Restrictions May Apply. We visit the place that is like a factory for our nation's most notorious fine print. Act four, May Be Hazardous To Children. Susan Burton rereads the fine print that changed her childhood. Stay with us.
今天我们的电台节目将讲述关于“小字条文”的故事。我们将深入探讨在那些真正重要的地方，小字条文是如何发挥作用的。第一幕，《副作用可能包括》——南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）带来了一个关于小字条文的故事，发生在你意想不到的地方。第二幕，《入住权可能随时被撤销且不另行通知》。在这个故事里，大卫·拉科夫（David Rakoff）带给我们那些能修复治疗无法触及之处的小字条文。第三幕，《可能存在限制》。我们参观的地方就像是我们国家最臭名昭著的小字条文加工厂。第四幕，《可能对儿童有害》。苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）重读了那份改变了她童年的小字条文。留下来，和我们在一起。
Act one, Side Effects May Include--
第一幕，《副作用可能包括》——
A confession is not supposed to have fine print. It's supposed to state this is what happened, this is what I did, all very straightforward. But of course, all kinds of confessions come with asterisks attached. This first story is about a confession that was given in Iran in the Fall of 2004, when things were actually a bit freer than they are right now. Nancy Updike tells what happened.
忏悔书本不该有小字条文。它应该说明发生了什么，我做了什么，一切都很直接。但当然，各种忏悔书都附带着星号。第一个故事是关于2004年秋天在伊朗给出的一份忏悔书，那时的情况实际上比现在要自由一些。南希·厄普代克讲述了发生了什么。
At 30 years old, Omid Memarian, a journalist in Iran, went where he wanted, talked to whomever he felt like talking to. Reformists, hardliners, foreigners, the vice president of the world bank, why not?
30岁的奥米德·梅马里安（Omid Memarian）是伊朗的一名记者，他想去哪就去哪，想跟谁说话就跟谁说话。改革派、强硬派、外国人、世界银行副行长，为什么不呢？
Political debate in Iran was robust. Omid's view was, he lived in a country that had problems. And he was a critic of those problems. But it also had a constitution, elections, some independent newspapers. Iran wasn't North Korea. It wasn't Myanmar.
伊朗的政治辩论非常热烈。奥米德的观点是，他生活在一个有问题的国家。他是一个批评者，指出那些问题。但这个国家也有宪法、选举、一些独立的报纸。伊朗不是朝鲜，也不是缅甸。
In October of 2004, Omid was arrested at his office by government men in plainclothes. Didn't have badges, did have guns. And within a few hours, Omid was sitting in an interrogation room at a prison whose name and location he didn't know. After a while, a man walked in.
2004年10月，奥米德在办公室被身着便装的政府人员逮捕。他们没有徽章，但有枪。几小时后，奥米德坐在监狱里的一间审讯室里，他不知道那间监狱的名字和位置。过了一会儿，一个男人走了进来。
Like 55 years old with a very short beard, and kind of calm. And I felt that this guy might be a nice guy. But when I said hi to this guy, then he just started beating me. And I was sitting next to the wall and on a chair. And the guy took my head, and was hitting my head to the wall. And he was doing that. And at one point I remember, the guy was asking me about my travel to the US.
大约55岁，留着很短的胡子，看起来很平静。我当时觉得这家伙可能是个好人。但当我向他问好时，他直接就开始打我。我坐在墙边的一把椅子上。那个人抓住我的头，不停地往墙上撞。就是这样。有一次我记得，那个人问我关于去美国旅行的事。
In 2004, I was invited to come here to the US and give a speech. So I got my visa. I went to Frankfurt Airport, and then somebody called my name. So they told me that my name was on the No Fly List, a list that I think Osama Bin Laden probably is on the top. So I took the first flight. And I went back home.
2004年，我被邀请去美国发表演讲。所以我拿到了签证。我到了法兰克福机场，有人叫了我的名字。他们告诉我我的名字在禁飞名单上，那个我想奥萨马·本·拉登可能排在名单榜首的名单。所以我坐了第一班飞机回了家。
So the interrogator was asking me what happened in Washington, DC. And I said, hi, I didn't go there. I was on the No Fly List. Probably you guys are there. We are all on this list. And the guy said, no, we have tapes of those meetings that you had in Washington, DC. We have all the documents. And I said, dude, I have not been there. Look at my passport. It doesn't show anything. There is no stamp on my passport.
所以审讯员问我华盛顿特区发生了什么。我说，嗨，我没去那儿。我在禁飞名单上。可能你们也在名单上，我们都在名单上。那个人说，不，我们有你在华盛顿开会的录音，我们有所有文件。我说，老兄，我没去过那儿。看我的护照。什么都没显示。我的护照上没有印章。
At that moment I learned that they really-- Americans-- they bluff. They just bluff.
在那一刻我意识到，他们确实——美国人——他们在虚张声势。他们只是在虚张声势。
And once you figured out that part of what they were doing was bluffing, was that a relief? Or was that more terrifying? Did that make you feel like, I have no idea what to do?
当你发现他们所做的一部分是虚张声势时，这是一种解脱吗？还是更令人恐惧？这让你觉得“我完全不知道该怎么办”吗？
When they bluffed, at the beginning I thought, oh, there is nothing here. But the thing was, when you have to talk about something that never happened, this was much harder than to talk about something that happened. Because when nothing was there, it was really hard to imagine that kind of incidence. I mean, this guy was beating me, and at one point, I was on the floor. He was hitting my stomach with his leg. In that case, I threw up. And I just couldn't accept that, because I'd never been to the US.
当他们虚张声势时，起初我以为，哦，什么都没有。但问题是，当你必须谈论从未发生过的事情时，这比谈论发生过的事情要困难得多。因为当什么都没有时，很难想象那种情景。我是说，那个人在打我，有一次我倒在地上。他用脚踢我的肚子。那种情况下，我吐了。我无法接受，因为我从未去过美国。
Forced confessions are not a new phenomenon, more like eternal. And Omid got the standard treatment-- beatings and solitary. But every government that forces confessions has its own variation on the process, its own way of building up its library of confessions.
强迫忏悔不是什么新现象，更像是永恒的。奥米德受到了标准的待遇——殴打和单独监禁。但每个强制忏悔的政府都有其独特的流程变体，有其建立忏悔库的独特方式。
He gave me a kind of notebook and a pen, and asked me to start writing everything you have done over the past seven years. And so I thought, that's fine. I can write everything. I don't have any secret. And there's nothing to be worried about.
他给了我一个笔记本和一支笔，让我开始写下过去七年里你做过的一切。我想，没问题。我可以写下一切。我没有任何秘密。没什么好担心的。
So he was there. I was sitting on a chair. And I started writing. There was a table there too. And every five minutes he asked me to see my writing. Every five minutes.
所以他在那儿。我坐在椅子上。我开始写。那儿也有一张桌子。每五分钟他就要看我写的东西。每五分钟。
And then when he saw what I was writing, he screamed at me and said, no, this is not what I want. This is not what I want from you. You should tell me the truth. And I said, this is the truth. And he said, no, you're hiding the truth. Tell me what happened behind the doors.
当他看到我写的内容时，他对我尖叫，说：不，这不是我要的。这不是我要你写的。你应该告诉我真相。我说，这就是真相。他说，不，你在隐瞒真相。告诉我门后发生了什么。
I had no idea what he wanted me to write for them. I had no idea, because I said in many cases that this is exactly what happened. This is exactly the people I met. Actually, I wrote a biography of myself for them. It was a very honest biography. I even talked about things I never talked to my mom, or my dad, or my friends.
我根本不知道他想让我写什么。我完全不知道，因为我在很多情况下都说了，这就是发生的全部事实。这就是我见过的所有人。实际上，我为他们写了一份个人传记。那是一份非常诚实的传记。我甚至写了一些我从未告诉过我妈妈、爸爸或朋友的事情。
They asked about my girlfriends. In Iran you can not have a girlfriend when you are not married. The guy asked me to confess about my sexual relationship.
他们问我的女朋友。在伊朗，如果你没结婚，是不能有女朋友的。那个人让我忏悔我的性关系。
Tell me how you started. Do you use condom? Did you use porn? Did you watch porn?
告诉我你是怎么开始的。你用避孕套吗？你看色情片吗？你看色情片吗？
I start crying. I begged him. I begged him, please, do not ask that. Please do not ask that. I can not do that. And I was like, oh my God. Where are you going from here? And he forced me to write that.
我开始哭。我求他。我求他，拜托，不要问那个。拜托不要问那个。我做不到。我当时想，我的天哪。你还要怎么折磨我？他强迫我写了下来。
They told me all the time, you're going to stay here for six months, a year, two years. You're not going to go home. Forget it. And I was so devastated. I felt so hopeless. And I said, God, please help me. These people are doing this with me with your name, you know, reading Koran, praying five times a day. The guy was beating me, and sometimes stopped beating me to pray on time.
他们一直告诉我，你会在这里呆上六个月、一年、两年。你回不了家了。忘了它吧。我非常沮丧。我感到无比绝望。我说，上帝，请帮帮我。这些人以你的名义对我做这些事，你知道，读着《古兰经》，一天祈祷五次。那个人在打我，有时打到一半停下来去按时祈祷。
And the thing is, I remember once I watched a movie. Its name is Irreversible . It was in my mind all the time, that there is a point in everybody's life that your life separates to before that event and after that. So for me, I knew that there's a point that I can not take more pressure. I knew people who stayed for a long time in prison, and they never be able to come back to their normal life. They never become normal persons.
关键是，我记得有一次我看了一部电影。名字叫《不可撤销》（Irreversible）。它一直在我脑海里，每个人的一生都有一个点，你的生活分为那个事件之前和之后。所以对我来说，我知道有一个点是我无法再承受更多压力了。我认识那些在监狱里呆了很长时间的人，他们永远无法回到正常生活。他们再也变不回正常人了。
They never recovered.
他们从未恢复过来。
They never recovered. And I knew those people. I talked to those people. I didn't want to be those people at the age of 30. And at one point when their pressure was so high, I thought I was entering to the irreversible part.
他们从未恢复过来。我认识那些人。我和那些人谈过。我不想在30岁时变成那样。当压力达到极大时，我以为我正在进入那段“不可撤销”的部分。
In the third week, he gave in.
在第三周，他屈服了。
I said, OK, what do you want me to write for you? And they said, so these are the names, these are the topics.
我说，好，你们想让我写什么？他们说，好吧，这些是名字，这些是主题。
I drafted my story. It was the only unpaid story I have written in my life. I'm always paid. But anyways.
我起草了我的故事。这是我一生中写的唯一一篇没有稿费的故事。我写文章总是有稿费的。但不管怎样。
The only unpaid story you've ever written in your life was your false confession?
你一生中写的唯一一篇没有稿费的故事就是你的虚假忏悔书？
Yes. I drafted my story. I gave it to my interrogator. And then he was like my editor. He changed some of the names. And he just changed the order. And then he gave me a few pages analysis. And I had to include those approaches-- those lines-- in my confessions.
是的。我起草了故事，给了我的审讯员。然后他就像我的编辑一样。他改了一些名字，改了顺序。然后他给了我几页分析材料。我必须把那些方法——那些台词——包含在我的忏悔书里。
Your interrogator is literally writing on your draft? He's making notes in the margins, and crossing things out, and adding things like an editor?
你的审讯员真的在你的草稿上写字吗？他在页边空白处做笔记，划掉东西，像编辑一样添加内容？
Exactly like that. He gave me directions. For example, I said I wrote for this newspaper or that newspaper. I went to these countries. I met these people. So in their version it was, with the suggestion of that politician, I went to this country. And I was a part of a plan. It was a big plan. And I had to say that I intentionally-- and sometimes, unintentionally-- I have cooperated with them through my writings, through my blog, through my travels, through my talks, and that kind of things.
完全一样。他给我指示。例如，我说我为这份报纸或那份报纸写过稿。我去过这些国家，见过这些人。所以他们的版本是：在某位政治家的建议下，我去了那个国家，我是某个计划的一部分。那是个大计划。我必须说我是有意——有时是无意——与他们合作，通过我的文章、我的博客、我的旅行、我的谈话以及诸如此类的事情。
Were there specific words he wanted you to use?
他有没有要求你使用特定的词语？
Definitely I had to use velvet revolution.
我一定要使用“天鹅绒革命”这个词。
And how do you say velvet revolution in Farsi?
波斯语里怎么说“天鹅绒革命”？
[SPEAKING FARSI]
[波斯语发音]
And he wanted you to put those exact words in?
他要求你必须用那几个词？
Exact words.
确切的词。
Confessions in Iran are sometimes broadcast on TV. They show up in the evenings on the state-run news programs. Transcripts of confessions are also posted on government websites. And watching, reading, and hearing about one Iranian confession after another, it's impossible not to notice a distinct and unchanging editorial vision at work here. Because the fact is, people in Iran who have never met each other have nevertheless been confessing to a lot of the same things, in a lot of the same ways, for at least 10 years.
伊朗的忏悔书有时会在电视上播放。它们出现在晚间的国家新闻节目中。忏悔书的文字稿也会张贴在政府网站上。看着、读着、听着一个又一个伊朗人的忏悔，不可能不注意到这里存在着一种独特且一成不变的编辑视角。因为事实是，伊朗那些彼此从未见过面的人，至少在过去10年里，一直以同样的方式、忏悔着同样的事情。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语发音]
In these video clips from this summer following the disputed election, one ordinary Iranian after another is confessing to having been manipulated by the BBC and Voice of America to cause mayhem or undermine the regime. And here's another confession. There's no tape. But we've got a transcript. It's a TV confession from a few weeks ago. Maziar Bahari, a documentary filmmaker and reporter for Newsweek in Iran, was arrested after the election. And he's still in custody. His confession is a classic of the genre. It's so crammed with buzz phrases and bullet points that in some parts it gets hard to understand.
在今年夏天关于选举争议的视频片段中，一个又一个普通的伊朗人忏悔说自己被英国广播公司（BBC）和美国之音操纵，以制造骚乱或破坏政权。这是另一份忏悔书。没有录像，但我们有文字稿。这是几周前的一个电视忏悔。马齐亚尔·巴哈里（Maziar Bahari），一名纪录片导演和《新闻周刊》驻伊朗记者，在选举后被捕。他现在仍被拘留。他的忏悔是此类流派的经典之作。里面塞满了流行词汇和要点，以至于有些部分很难理解。
It says quote, "I, as a journalist, and as part of the huge capitalist machinery of the West, sometimes blindly, and sometimes intentionally, positioned myself on the side that was suggesting that a color revolution was underway. According to the models of color and velvet revolutions, we can consider the incidents in recent weeks as classic but defeated examples of a color revolution because it has the same properties as a color revolution."
上面写着，引文：“我，作为一名记者，作为西方巨大资本机器的一部分，有时是盲目地，有时是有意地，将自己置于建议‘颜色革命’正在发生的一方。根据颜色革命和天鹅绒革命的模式，我们可以将近几周的事件视为颜色革命的经典但被击败的例子，因为它具有与颜色革命相同的性质。”
When Omid heard that a transcript of this guy Maziar's confession was going to be released, he bet a friend who'd also been imprisoned in Iran that they could guess what would show up in Maziar's confession. So they wrote down their guesses. When they read the confession, they were stunned at how right they were.
当奥米德听说马齐亚尔的忏悔文字稿将要公布时，他和一个同样在伊朗坐过牢的朋友打赌，他们能猜到马齐亚尔的忏悔书里会出现什么。于是他们写下了猜测。当他们读到那份忏悔书时，他们被自己猜得有多准而惊呆了。
Because what Maziar Bahari said, this was not Maziar's language. Everybody who knows Maziar, everybody who knows the other guy, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. I mean [UNINTELLIGIBLE] used to work in the same newspaper. Nice guy. They didn't talk with their language. It was the interrogator's language. It's the security forces language. What he said was kind of analysis. I read that analysis inside the prison. It was the same. The narrative was very clear. The foreigners, they are influencing society. They want to change the society. Velvet revolution.
因为马齐亚尔·巴哈里所说的，根本不是马齐亚尔的语言。每一个认识马齐亚尔的人，每一个认识那个人的人……我是说，以前在同一家报社工作过，好人。他们用的不是他们自己的语言。那是审讯员的语言。是安全部队的语言。他说的是某种分析。我在监狱里读过那种分析。完全一样。叙事非常清晰。外国人，他们正在影响社会。他们想改变社会。天鹅绒革命。
Another recurring part of the narrative is the inclusion of the names of foreign people and institutions whenever possible, hopefully famous ones. The BBC, CNN, Newsweek, The New York Times , George Soros, President Clinton, UCLA, Princeton, all have appeared in various confessions.
叙事中另一个反复出现的部分是，尽可能地加入外国人和机构的名字，最好是那些出名的。BBC、CNN、《新闻周刊》、《纽约时报》、乔治·索罗斯、克林顿总统、加州大学洛杉矶分校、普林斯顿大学，都出现在各种忏悔书中。
I talked to one former student activist arrested in 2000, Ali Afshari, who confessed to intentionally criticizing the supreme leader, and unintentionally trying to overthrow the regime. Ali's interrogator tried to get him to write into his confession that former CIA director George Tenet had personally guided the overthrowing plan. Of course, the CIA did famously orchestrate an overthrow in Iran in 1953, a truth that for many Iranians, no doubt, makes anything seem possible. But for Ali, the idea that he, as a student activist, had been a lackey for George Tenet was absurd and insulting. It was as though his confession was a historical novel. And his editor kept trying to get him to beef up the realness by sprinkling in actual historical figures.
我采访了一位2000年被捕的前学生活动家阿里·阿夫沙里（Ali Afshari），他忏悔说有意批评最高领袖，无意中试图推翻政权。阿里的审讯员试图让他写进忏悔书，说前中央情报局局长乔治·特内特（George Tenet）亲自指导了推翻计划。当然，中情局在1953年确实在伊朗策划过一次政变，对于许多伊朗人来说，这个事实无疑使任何事情看起来都有可能发生。但对阿里来说，作为一名学生活动家，他是乔治·特内特的走狗这种想法简直荒谬且具有侮辱性。这就像他的忏悔书是一本历史小说，而他的编辑一直在试图通过撒入真实的历史人物来增加真实感。
By now, Iranian political confessions have become so repetitive and recognizable that one of Iran's most famous political satirists, Ebrahim Nabavi, recently posted a fake one on YouTube.
时至今日，伊朗的政治忏悔已经变得如此重复和可识别，以至于伊朗最著名的政治讽刺作家之一易卜拉欣·纳巴维（Ebrahim Nabavi）最近在YouTube上发布了一个虚假的忏悔视频。
[SPEAKING FOEIGN LANGUAGE]
[外语发音]
The comedian is dressed in prison stripes, and identifies himself as Mohammad Ali Abtahi, the former vice president of Iran. If that seems like part of the joke, it isn't. Abtahi is one of the hundreds of people who've been in prison since the election.
这个喜剧演员穿着囚服，自称是穆罕默德·阿里·阿布塔希（Mohammad Ali Abtahi），伊朗前副总统。如果这看起来像笑话的一部分，那不是。阿布塔希是选举后被关进监狱的数百人之一。
In the spoof, the comedian looks sheepishly at the camera and says, "I confess that when I travelled to holy Mecca, I met with one of the agents from the frightening CIA. He called me, and offered me to do a velvet revolution."
在讽刺视频中，喜剧演员害羞地看着镜头说：“我忏悔，当我去圣城麦加旅行时，我见到了可怕的中情局的特工之一。他打电话给我，提议让我做一场天鹅绒革命。”
There are obvious edits in the satire video. And over the course of the story, the comedian's face gets covered in more and more Band-Aids. As he continues, he admits that he eventually agreed to do the velvet revolution, as long as he could do it his way.
讽刺视频中有明显的剪辑。随着故事的进展，喜剧演员的脸上贴满了创可贴。继续往下说，他承认他最终同意做天鹅绒革命，只要能按他的方式做。
"I imported a few bolts of green velvet fabrics from Israel and England. During this time-- in addition to millions of dollars of funding that was handed to me by Christiane Amanpour-- I also started the green velvet fabric business."
“我从以色列和英国进口了几匹绿色天鹅绒布料。在此期间——除了克里斯蒂安·阿曼普尔（Christiane Amanpour）交给我的数百万美元资助外——我还开始了绿色天鹅绒布料生意。”
Later in the story, he suggests to one of his co-conspirators that they should change their revolution to focus on a cheaper fabric than velvet. The comedian, by the way, was himself forced to confess years ago. He no longer lives in Iran.
在故事后面，他向一名共同阴谋者建议，他们应该把革命重点改为更便宜的布料，而不是天鹅绒。顺便说一句，这个喜剧演员本人多年前也被迫忏悔过。他不再住在伊朗了。
These confessions, for all their heavy-handedness, have been crushingly effective. They've ended careers, driven people out of the country, and kept others looking over their shoulder for the rest of their lives. Because the bargain is, confess and there's a good chance you'll be released. Probably. Eventually.
这些忏悔，尽管手段拙劣，却非常有效。它们摧毁了职业生涯，迫使人们逃离国家，并让其他人余生都在担惊受怕中度过。因为交易内容是：忏悔，你就有很好的机会被释放。也许吧。最终。
But the state could decide to bring a case against you afterward anyway. Or they could go after your friends and family. Or with all the personal details you've confessed along with the political ones, the security services could blackmail you into working for them as a propagandist, an informant.
但国家可能决定事后还是会对你提起诉讼。或者他们可能会找你的朋友和家人的麻烦。或者随着你在政治忏悔的同时交出的所有个人细节，安全部门可以勒索你，让你为他们充当宣传员或告密者。
Meanwhile, many Iranians, even today, believe the confessions are genuine, or at least could be. For those who get their news mostly from the state-run TV channels, the confessions seem as real as anything else on the news.
与此同时，许多伊朗人即使在今天，仍然相信这些忏悔是真实的，或者至少可能是真实的。对于那些主要从国家运营的电视频道获取新闻的人来说，这些忏悔看起来和新闻中的其他内容一样真实。
Even Omid, before he was arrested, sometimes wondered if the stories he'd heard about torture and forced confessions were exaggerations, or even made up all together. Like I said, very effective.
即使是奥米德，在被捕前，有时也会怀疑他听到的关于酷刑和强迫忏悔的故事是否是夸大其词，甚至是编造出来的。就像我说的，非常有效。
I really understood at one point that it's not all about me. They are gathering information about the reformists. I mean, for example, they gave me names at one point. And I said, I have never seen these people. I know these people, I have never seen these people. And I can not say that I have met them, or they have directed me, or they have guided me. And they told me that it's OK. When you confess and when you use their names in your confession, it will be so alarming for them. So they wanted to intimidate those people, those reformists, as well. They didn't care that I didn't meet any of those people. So the people who are in prison now, ranking reformists, they had been after them like for five, six years. They just didn't decide to arrest them [UNINTELLIGIBLE] after the election. They had been planning for this for years.
我真的在某一刻明白了，这不仅仅是关于我自己的事。他们在收集关于改革派的信息。例如，他们给了我名单。我说，我从来没见过这些人。我认识他们，但我从来没见过这些人。我不能说我见过他们，或者他们指挥过我，或者他们引导过我。他们告诉我没关系。当你忏悔时使用他们的名字，这会对他们非常令人警惕。所以他们也想恐吓那些人，那些改革派。他们不在乎我是否见过那些人。所以现在在监狱里的那些人，高级改革派，他们已经追踪他们五六年了。他们只是没决定在选举后逮捕他们……他们已经为此计划多年了。
Omid wrote six drafts for his interrogator by his own estimate. And out of that, they shaped a 5,000 word version and a shorter 2,000 word op-ed style version. Excerpts were printed in several newspapers. And then he had to confess on TV.
奥米德据他自己估计，为审讯员写了六个草稿。在此基础上，他们整理出了一个5000字的版本和一个更短的2000字评论文章版本。部分内容在几份报纸上刊登了。然后他还必须在电视上忏悔。
And they told me, my interrogator said, this is the last part of the game. You should be on TV, and it's over. Don't screw us.
他们告诉我，我的审讯员说，这是游戏的最后一部分。你需要在电视上忏悔，一切就结束了。别搞砸了。
Some TV confessions in Iran are the stark, looking straight at the camera confession you're probably imagining. But with other people-- journalists, or politicians, or big activists-- often it's staged as an informal interview-- in a room set up with chairs, a table, maybe some flowers-- as though, they're sitting down for a chat with Matt Lauer.
伊朗的一些电视忏悔是你可能想象的那种直视镜头的严肃忏悔。但对于其他人——记者、政客或大活动家——通常会被安排成一种非正式的采访——在摆放了椅子、桌子、可能还有一些花卉的房间里——就好像他们坐下来和马特·劳尔（Matt Lauer）聊天一样。
It was a beautiful room decorated beautifully with curtain, flowers, chairs, orange juice. But the thing was I wanted to make it more unprofessional. So they had to cut all the time. Saying, cut. Again. Omid, what are you doing?
那是一个装饰得非常漂亮的房间，有窗帘、花卉、椅子、橙汁。但问题是我想让它看起来更不专业。所以他们一直要喊停。“卡！重来。奥米德，你在干什么？”
A few times I cried. It was unintentional and also intentional. Both. I didn't want to make it very easy for them.
我有几次哭了。这是无意的，也是有意的。两者都有。我不想让他们太容易得逞。
And was your chief interrogator there behind the camera saying, you know, you did it wrong. Do it again?
你的首席审讯员当时在镜头后面说：“你知道，你做错了。重来。”
Yes, he was there. And he asked me to stop. And I had to start again. So it took four hours to finish half an hour confession.
是的，他在那儿。他让我停下来，我不得不重新开始。所以半小时的忏悔用了四个小时才完成。
After Omid was released in December of 2004, he leaked to Human Rights Watch that he and about 19 others who'd been arrested around the same time had been coerced into confessing. And the shocking thing was, many top government officials-- when they heard what had happened to Omid and the others-- were shocked. Officials like the president, moderate reformist Mohammed Khatami, and his ministers. It caused an uproar.
奥米德在2004年12月获释后，向“人权观察”透露，他和当时同时被捕的其他约19人被胁迫进行了忏悔。令人震惊的是，许多高层政府官员——当他们听到奥米德和其他人的遭遇时——都感到震惊。像总统、温和改革派穆罕默德·哈塔米（Mohammed Khatami）和他的部长们这样的官员。这引起了轩然大波。
And eventually Omid and another young journalist met with the head of the judiciary, the Grand Ayatollah Shahroudi. He's still the head of the judiciary today. He's the Iranian equivalent of the attorney general.
最终，奥米德和另一位年轻记者会见了司法总监、大阿亚图拉沙赫鲁迪（Shahroudi）。他至今仍是司法总监。他是伊朗的司法部长。
And Omid learned that the security force's standard procedure with the confessions was to make copies, and send them along to government officials and top ayatollahs as proof that there were Iranian citizens bent on undermining and plotting against the state. And because the interrogators took so much care to make the confessions look unforced-- with the flowers and the vase, and the chatty interviewer, the confessing person not looking beat up or emaciated-- apparently the videos were pretty convincing.
奥米德了解到，安全部队处理忏悔的标准程序是复制备份，并将其发送给政府官员和高级阿亚图拉，作为证明有伊朗公民意图破坏和策划反对国家的证据。而且因为审讯员非常谨慎地让忏悔看起来是自愿的——配上鲜花和花瓶，还有健谈的采访者，忏悔者看起来没有被打得鼻青脸肿或憔悴不堪——显然这些视频非常有说服力。
When Omid and the other journalist told the head of the judiciary everything that had led up to their confessions, it was clear to Omid that he was hearing these things for the first time.
当奥米德和其他记者告诉司法总监导致他们忏悔的一切经历时，奥米德很清楚，他是第一次听到这些。
I really trusted this guy. I felt that he was very honest. He had a very honest reaction. I could see in his face he was so angry. And he was saying all the time, [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]. You know, people use it when they do not believe something, or something's very astounding for them.
我真的很信任这个人。我感觉他非常诚实。他有非常诚实的反应。我能看到他脸上非常愤怒。他一直都在说[波斯语发音]。你知道，人们在不相信某事或某事对他们来说非常惊人时会用这个词。
But for all the shock, and outrage, and the promises to look into what had happened and take action, nothing changed. Not because the head of the judiciary, or anyone else, was insincere, Omid thinks. They just weren't, and possibly aren't, strong enough to fight what was happening.
但尽管感到震惊、愤怒，尽管承诺调查发生了什么并采取行动，什么都没改变。奥米德认为，不是因为司法总监或其他任何人不真诚。他们只是不够强大，可能现在也不够强大，去对抗正在发生的事情。
Many people, they are not happy, even in the conservative camp, even among Ahmadinejad supporters. They are really mad at what is going on. In my case, I remember that many people on the judiciary and in the government-- conservatives, that I had a chance to talk to them-- they told me that they are so stunned at how these guys are brutal, and why they are doing this, and how they are not responsible.
很多人并不高兴，即使在保守派阵营中，即使在内贾德的支持者中。他们对正在发生的事情感到非常愤怒。以我为例，我记得司法部门和政府中的许多人——那些我有机会交谈过的保守派——他们告诉我，他们对这些人是多么残忍感到震惊，为什么他们要这样做，以及他们为什么不负责任。
Last week, the lieutenant commander of Iran's Basij militia was quoted saying, "There are now so many confessions obtained from rioters that even if all the media mobilized for a long time to broadcast them, they still couldn't get all the information out to the people."
上周，伊朗巴斯基民兵副指挥官被引述说：“现在从暴徒那里获得的忏悔如此之多，即使所有媒体动员很长一段时间去播放它们，他们仍然无法将所有信息传达给民众。”
A few days before that story came out, one of the most senior ayatollahs in Iran, the Grand Ayatollah Montazeri, said in a translation on the Middle East Media Research Institute Website, "The proud people of Iran know very well exactly how authentic the detainees' confessions are. They are like confessions obtained by fascist and communist regimes. The nation knows that the false confessions and televised interviews were obtained from its imprisoned sons with threats and torture, and that their aim is to cover up the oppression and injustice, and to present a distorted image of the people's peaceful and legal protest."
在那篇报道出来的几天前，伊朗最资深的大阿亚图拉之一，大阿亚图拉蒙塔泽里（Montazeri），在中东媒体研究所网站的一篇翻译稿中说：“伊朗引以为傲的人民非常清楚地知道被拘留者的忏悔到底有多真实。它们就像法西斯和共产主义政权获得的忏悔一样。国家知道这些虚假忏悔和电视采访是从其被监禁的儿子们那里通过威胁和酷刑获得的，其目的是掩盖压迫和不公正，并呈现人民和平、合法抗议的扭曲形象。”
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制片人之一。
Coming up, the fine print that keeps mom in her place. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来的节目，让母亲待在她该待的地方的小字条文。稍后回来。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Fine Print.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。每周在节目中我们都会选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的各种故事。今天的节目，《小字条文》。
Usually, most of us try to just skip the fine print. You know, we don't read the rental car agreements or the software license end user agreements. We just click I Agree.
通常，我们大多数人都会尽量跳过小字条文。你知道，我们不读租车协议或软件许可终端用户协议。我们只是点击“我同意”。
Today on our show we have stories where the fine print has real consequences. We've arrived at act two of our show. Act two, Occupancy May Be Revoked Without Notice. This next bit of fine print was brought to us by David Rakoff.
今天在我们的节目中，我们有关于小字条文带来真实后果的故事。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，《入住权可能随时被撤销且不另行通知》。这下一条小字条文由大卫·拉科夫带来。
The following shall constitute the binding agreement between Mr. Gregory [? Stolzenberg ?] of Yonkers, New York, hereafter known as owner, and his mother, Mrs. Barbara [? Stolzenberg ?] of Tenafly, New Jersey, hereafter known as mother, in regards to the third floor bedroom of number 41 old [? Alewive's ?] Lane, Yonkers, New York.
以下构成纽约州扬克斯市的格雷戈里·斯托尔岑贝格（Gregory Stolzenberg）先生（以下简称业主）与其母亲，新泽西州泰纳弗利的芭芭拉·斯托尔岑贝格（Barbara Stolzenberg）夫人（以下简称母亲）之间关于纽约州扬克斯老艾勒威斯巷41号三楼卧室的约束性协议。
One. Upon completion of chemotherapy and surgery at the Memorial Sloan-Kettering Cancer Center, Mother shall take occupancy for an as yet undetermined period of time, hereafter known as convalescent period, not to exceed four weeks in duration.
一、在纪念斯隆-凯特琳癌症中心完成化疗和手术后，母亲应入住一段尚未确定的时间，以下简称恢复期，时长不超过四周。
Two. A front door key will be left underneath the stone frog near the rhododendron. Mother agrees to return said key to its hiding place, for once.
二、前门钥匙将留在杜鹃花旁边的石蛙下。母亲同意像往常一样，将钥匙放回原处。
Three. Mother acknowledges herewith that she is aware that as a converted attic, the third floor and its bedroom are accessible by a retractable ladder.
三、母亲在此承认，她知道作为改建阁楼，三楼及其卧室只能通过伸缩梯进入。
Subparagraph one. Mother hereby waives any and all recourse to the Americans with Disabilities Act and to any liability on the owner's part in the event of any injury.
子条款一。母亲在此放弃任何及所有诉诸《美国残疾人法案》的权利，并免除业主在发生任何伤害时的任何责任。
Subparagraph two. Included in mother's accommodation, she shall be given 24 hour access to the bathroom on the second floor.
子条款二。母亲的住宿费用中包含二楼浴室的全天候使用权。
Four. Per mother's previous request, she shall occupy the lower bunk of the third floor bedroom while owner's eight-year-old son, Robbie [? Stolzenberg, ?] shall occupy the top bunk.
四、应母亲之前的要求，她将占用三楼卧室的下铺，而业主八岁的儿子罗比·斯托尔岑贝格（Robbie Stolzenberg）将占用上铺。
Five. Mother may take breakfast and supper with the family-- please see attached appendix detailing the meal plan-- and agrees that upon finishing eating, she will quote, "make herself scarce." As has been previously and frequently discussed, quote, "sitting quietly with a magazine, and not saying a word even if you begged me to say something," unquote, differs wholly in spirit, letter, and intention from making oneself scarce.
五、母亲可以与家人共进早餐和晚餐——请参阅附录详细说明的膳食计划——并同意在用餐结束后，“让自己消失”。正如之前频繁讨论过的，“安静地坐着看杂志，即使你求我说一个字我也不说”，在精神、文字和意图上都与让自己消失完全不同。
Mother further agrees not to do quote, "that thing with the chewing and the breathing."
母亲进一步同意不进行“那种咀嚼和呼吸的声音”。
Subparagraph one. Further to the matter of quote, "making oneself scarce," unquote-- and it is herein that this subparagraph not be construed as belaboring a matter to the point of obsession-- but mother further concedes herein that both owner and his wife have been medically assessed to be of excellent to above average hearing. And as such, any and all comments-- even those spoken at a whisper-- are perfectly audible.
子条款一。进一步说明关于“让自己消失”的问题——本子条款不应被解读为对该问题的纠缠到了强迫症的地步——但母亲在此进一步承认，业主及其妻子的听力经医学评估为优至优以上。因此，任何及所有评论——即使是耳语——都是完全可听见的。
Further, owner's wife as a Mexican born Catholic, and therefore not possessed of a formal Yiddish education, is well aware that the word curva has entered common English usage to mean whore. And the use of said word, even when muttered, is heard, and emphatically not appreciated.
此外，业主的妻子作为出生于墨西哥的天主教徒，虽然没有受过正式的意第绪语教育，但很清楚“curva”这个词已进入通俗英语使用，意为妓女。而使用该词，即使是喃喃自语，也会被听到，且绝不被接受。
Six. Mother may make daily use of the public rooms on the main floor, such as the living room from 11:00 AM to 3:00 PM, or until Robbie [? Stolzenberg ?] returns home from school, whichever happens sooner, at which time mother must relinquish the television remote and quote, "make herself scarce," unquote. See paragraph five.
六、母亲可以在上午11点至下午3点期间使用主楼层的公共区域，例如客厅，或者直到罗比·斯托尔岑贝格放学回家，以较早者为准，届时母亲必须交出电视遥控器并“让自己消失”。见第五条。
Mother may receive visitors, no more than two a day. Although under no circumstances may mother receive her daughter, the omniscient and perfect-- it is acknowledged that both adjectives are being employed ironically-- Mrs. Marla [? Stolzenberg ?] Burns of Ho-Ho-Kus, New Jersey for reasons that have been previously and frequently discussed.
母亲可以接待访客，每天不超过两人。但在任何情况下，母亲不得接待她的女儿，即那位全知全能的——承认这两个形容词带有讽刺意味——玛拉·斯托尔岑贝格·伯恩斯（Marla Stolzenberg Burns）夫人，原因已在之前频繁讨论过。
If Mrs. [? Stolzenberg ?] Burns's eagerness to see her mother is deemed as so overwhelming, then perhaps the entire location of the convalescent period can be reassessed. Just say the word. Go on, say it. Say it. Say it.
如果玛拉·斯托尔岑贝格·伯恩斯夫人见她母亲的心情被认为太强烈，那么也许整个恢复期的地点可以重新评估。说出来。快，说出来。说出来。说出来。
Subparagraph one. Mention is made hereby that in the matter of the husband of the omniscient and perfect Mrs. Marla [? Stolzenberg ?] Burns, the owner's brother-in-law, Dr. Howard Burns of Ho-Ho-Kus, New Jersey. Mother further agrees that there is a material difference between a dermatologist and God almighty, and that there are, indeed, many things that the former does not know regardless of how much he pulls down annually.
子条款一。在此提及关于全知全能的玛拉·斯托尔岑贝格·伯恩斯夫人的丈夫，即业主的姐夫，新泽西州霍霍库斯的霍华德·伯恩斯（Dr. Howard Burns）医生的问题。母亲进一步同意皮肤科医生和上帝全能之间存在实质性差异，而且即使他每年赚那么多钱，前者确实有很多不知道的事情。
Seven. All efforts have been made herein to draft an impartial agreement with malice and favor towards none. This document is to serve as a mutual protection to both parties. And the full execution of which, it is hoped, will avert any future difficulties that might in any way resemble events of Thanksgiving 2005, 2006, 2007, or August 2008 at the beach.
七、此处已尽一切努力起草一份对双方皆无恶意和偏袒的公正协议。本文件旨在作为双方的共同保护。希望本文件的完全执行能避免未来任何可能以某种方式类似于2005年、2006年、2007年感恩节或2008年8月海滩事件的困难。
David Rakoff is the author of several books, including Don't Get Too Comfortable.
大卫·拉科夫是几本书的作者，包括《别让自己太舒服》（Don't Get Too Comfortable）。
Act three, Restrictions May Apply.
第三幕，《可能存在限制》。
At this point even die hard news consumers have to admit this sad truth about the health care debate. It's usually really, really boring. I ask you, is there any writer in the English language gifted enough to compose an interesting sentence involving the long-term financial health of Medicare? No, there is not.
在这一点上，即使是最坚定的新闻消费者也不得不承认关于医疗保健辩论的一个悲哀事实。它通常真的很无聊。我问你，英语语言中有哪位作家有足够的才华写出涉及医疗保险（Medicare）长期财务健康的有趣句子吗？不，没有。
But a month ago, a House subcommittee held a hearing where a handful of congresspeople could tear into witnesses with the zeal of starving men eating their first real meal in months. They found a corner of the health care crisis that anybody could understand, that would make anybody mad, that anybody would want to get in there and fix. It didn't get much coverage, this hearing. It was the Subcommittee on Oversight and Investigations of the House Committee on Energy and Commerce. And here is its chairman Bart Stupak of Michigan, reviewing the fine print of an insurance application with Don Hamm, who's the head of the insurance company that issued it, Assurant Health.
但一个月前，众议院的一个小组委员会举行了一次听证会，几位国会议员可以以饥饿的人吃几个月来第一顿真正的饭菜的那种热情去质问证人。他们发现了医疗危机的一个每个人都能理解、会让每个人生气、每个人都想进去修复的角落。这次听证会没有得到太多报道。它是众议院能源和商务委员会的监督和调查小组委员会。这是其主席、密歇根州的巴特·斯图帕克（Bart Stupak），他正在检查一份保险申请的小字条文，与会者是发出该申请的保险公司Assurant Health的负责人唐·哈姆（Don Hamm）。
What the congressman is trying to figure out in this first clip I'm going to play you is, are these insurance application forms intentionally difficult, so an average person would make mistakes filling them out? Mistakes that would later let the insurance company deny them benefits, or cancel their policy.
众议员在我要播放的这段剪辑中试图弄清楚的是：这些保险申请表格是否是故意设置得很困难，以便普通人在填写时犯错？这些错误后来会让保险公司拒绝赔付或者取消他们的保单。
As you said, your Assurant Health questionnaires are simple, easy to understand, straightforward language, so people can easily and accurately report their medical history. So let me ask you this. In your policy, Mr. Hamm, it states in question number 14, "Within the last 10 years, has any proposed insured had any diagnosis, received treatment for, or consulted with a physician concerning phlebitis, TIA, [? cystitis, ?] lymphadenopathy, or glandular disorder?" So tell me, what is TIA?
正如你所说，你们Assurant Health的问卷很简单，容易理解，语言直接，以便人们可以轻松准确地报告他们的病史。所以让我问你这个问题。在你的保单中，哈姆先生，第14条写着：“在过去10年内，是否有任何被保险人被诊断出、接受过治疗，或咨询过医生有关静脉炎、短暂性脑缺血（TIA）、膀胱炎、淋巴结病或腺体疾病的问题？”那么告诉我，什么是TIA？
I am not aware. I believe--
我不知道。我相信……
If you don't know what it is, how would anyone filling out your application know what it is? So there's grounds to deny them right there. You don't even know what it is, either do I.
如果你不知道它是什么，任何填写你们申请表的人怎么会知道它是什么？所以拒绝他们的理由就在那里。你甚至不知道它是什么，我也不知道。
How about phlebitis or lymphadenopathy? How about lymphadenopathy, what's that?
那静脉炎或淋巴结病呢？淋巴结病呢，那是什么？
I don't know the answer to those questions.
我不知道这些问题的答案。
Do you sincerely believe that an average applicant would know what these words mean, if you don't know and I don't know?
你真诚地相信，如果你和我不知道这些词的意思，普通申请人会知道吗？
Sir, I believe that is an application that is not currently used at this time. I would like to--
先生，我相信那是一份目前不再使用的申请表。我想……
It's last year's application. Last year's application. Have you changed the application in the last year?
那是去年的申请表。去年的申请表。你们过去一年改过申请表吗？
I'm not aware if we have changed that application.
我不知道我们是否改过那份申请表。
His hearing was the culmination of a year-long investigation by the subcommittee into the fine print of our nation's insurance policies, and specifically, into something called rescission, for people who have their own, individual insurance. This doesn't apply to people get insurance through their jobs or group insurance policies. For people who have individual insurance, rescission is what happens when an insurance company decides that you lied when you applied for a policy with them-- you pretended that you were healthier than you really were, or you concealed a serious and expensive illness, or you simply made a mistake without intending to, and omitted something about your health that they might want to know. And so they cancel your policy. They rescind it.
这次听证会是小组委员会为期一年的调查的高潮，调查的是我国保险政策的小字条文，特别是针对那些拥有独立个人保险的人，即所谓的“撤销”（rescission）。这不适用于通过工作获得保险或团体保险政策的人。对于拥有个人保险的人，“撤销”是指保险公司认为你在申请保单时撒了谎——你假装自己比实际更健康，或者你隐瞒了严重的、昂贵的疾病，或者你只是无意中犯了一个错误，遗漏了一些他们想知道的健康状况。于是他们取消了你的保单。他们撤销了它。
The problem according to the subcommittee's investigation is that so many people get kicked off who weren't trying to deceive the insurance companies at all. They found that if you get an illness-- especially an expensive illness-- the insurance companies go looking for a way to kick you off.
根据小组委员会的调查，问题在于许多并没有试图欺骗保险公司的人被踢了出来。他们发现，如果你生了病——尤其是昂贵的疾病——保险公司就会去寻找把你踢出去的方法。
The subcommittee found a guy in Virginia who lost his coverage because the insurance agent who sold him the policy incorrectly wrote down the guy's weight on a form, and then never showed it to the guy to double check.
小组委员会在弗吉尼亚州发现了一个人，他因为销售保单的保险代理人错误地在表格上写了他的体重，而且从未让他核对，结果失去了保险。
A patient in Utah who needed surgery lost their insurance because of a mistake, an omission, on their spouse's application.
犹他州的一名患者因为配偶申请中的一个错误或遗漏而失去了保险。
I got a chance to talk with one of the lawmakers on the subcommittee, Congresswoman Jan Schakowsky, a democrat form Illinois. And she told me that even somebody like her, who has worked on health care issues for decades, was surprised to find out that this could happen.
我有机会与小组委员会的一位立法者，来自伊利诺伊州的民主党众议员简·沙科夫斯基（Jan Schakowsky）交谈。她告诉我，即使像她这样研究医疗保健问题几十年的专家，也惊讶地发现这种情况真的会发生。
I hadn't even heard of it before, that you could actually be paying premiums, and then exactly when you really need the health insurance, they go back and deny it.
在此之前我甚至没听说过，你真的在交保费，然后在你真正需要医疗保险的时候，他们回头否认了它。
And listening to this hearing, it seems like this was one of those cases where all of you really seemed really, truly angry.
听了这次听证会，看来这确实是你们所有人都真正感到生气的情况之一。
Really, truly, angry. Yes. In a very emotional and personal way. This wasn't just another issue.
真正地、非常地生气。是的。以一种非常感性和私人的方式。这不仅仅是另一个问题。
And explain why.
解释一下原因。
The very idea that a woman who has been diagnosed with aggressive breast cancer, who was insured, was suddenly told, we're not going to pay for this.
仅仅是这样一个想法：一个已经被诊断出患有侵袭性乳腺癌、拥有保险的女性，突然被告知“我们不会为此支付费用”。
My name is Robin Beaton. I'm 59 years old. I was a registered nurse for 30 years. In June 2008, I was diagnosed with invasive HER2 genetic breast cancer, a very aggressive form of this cancer. I needed a double mastectomy immediately.
我叫罗宾·比顿（Robin Beaton）。我59岁了。我做了30年的注册护士。2008年6月，我被诊断出患有侵袭性HER2遗传性乳腺癌，这是一种非常激进的癌症形式。我需要立即进行双侧乳房切除术。
The Friday before I was to have my double mastectomy, Blue Cross and Blue Shield called me by telephone and told me that my chart was red flagged. And what does that mean? They said that due to the dermatologist's report--
在我进行双乳切除手术前的那个星期五，蓝十字蓝盾（Blue Cross and Blue Shield）给我打电话，告诉我我的病历被红旗标记了。那意味着什么？他们说由于皮肤科医生的报告……
There was something on her chart earlier about a dermatitis that they took to mean pre-cancerous. And even though the dermatologist called and said, please, this is acne. Do not deny her her breast cancer treatment. They said, no. They said no.
她的病历早先有一些关于皮炎的记录，他们将其理解为癌前病变。尽管皮肤科医生打电话说：“求你了，这是痤疮。不要拒绝她的乳腺癌治疗。”他们说“不”。他们说了“不”。
He said please don't hold up her cancer surgery for this. He begged them. He was the nicest man. Anyway, they said that I would not be able to have my surgery on Monday. And they launched a medical investigation into my medical history.
他说：“求你了，不要因为这个推迟她的癌症手术。”他在求他们。他是个最好的人。不管怎样，他们说我周一不能进行手术。他们对我的病史进行了医疗调查。
I was frantic. I didn't know how to pay for my surgery. The hospital wanted a $30,000 deposit. Can you imagine having to walk around with cancer growing in your body with no insurance?
我当时快疯了。我不知道怎么支付手术费用。医院要求存30000美元。你能想象带着体内生长的癌症却没有任何保险吗？
And it took her months to finally get the surgery that she needed, by which time the tumor had doubled. And at the hearing, we took a break for five minutes while she composed herself. I mean, she was clearly ill. And that was so dramatic and moving to every member on the committee.
她花了几个月时间才最终做上了需要的手术，那时肿瘤已经翻倍了。在听证会上，我们休息了五分钟，让她平复心情。我是说，她显然生病了。这对委员会的每一位成员来说都非常有戏剧性和感人。
I go to a cancer support group every week. Four girls in my cancer support group have had their insurance cancelled. It is very difficult for me to speak out. My insurance could be canceled again. I live in fear every day of my insurance company.
我每周都去一个癌症互助组。我癌症互助组里的四个女孩被取消了保险。对我来说说出来非常困难。我的保险可能再次被取消。我每天都活在对保险公司的恐惧中。
Looking at the face of a woman who had fast-moving breast cancer that could take her life, I just could not understand how the people who were testifying for the insurance industry could sleep at night. As people, as individuals, how could they defend this policy?
看着那个患有会导致死亡的快速发展乳腺癌的女性的脸，我真的无法理解那些为保险业作证的人晚上怎么睡得着觉。作为普通人、作为个体，他们怎么能为这种政策辩护？
I remember there was one moment in the hearing where somebody on the panel actually asked, does it bother you that people are going to die because of these policies?
我记得在听证会上有一个时刻，委员会里的某个人实际上问：“人们会因为这些政策而死亡，这让你感到困扰吗？”
Doesn't it bother you that people are going to die because you insist on reviewing a policy that somebody took out in good faith and forgot to tell you that they were being treated for acne? Doesn't that bother you?
人们会因为你坚持审查某人诚心诚意签署的保单，而对方忘记告诉你他正在接受痤疮治疗，从而导致他们死亡，这难道不让你感到困扰吗？
Yes sir, it does. And we regret the necessity that that has to occur even a single time.
是的，先生，确实。对于不得不发生这种情况，哪怕只有一次，我们感到遗憾。
There were three heads of insurance companies at this hearing. Don Hamm of Assurant Health, Richard Collins of UnitedHealth's Golden Rule Insurance Company, and Brian Sassi of WellPoint. And it seemed like they'd all been advised-- like a lot of corporate guys are in situations like this-- not to give an inch on anything. They would not admit, for instance, the premise of the hearing, that they go looking for people to throw off their rolls in order to save money.
听证会有三位保险公司负责人。Assurant Health的唐·哈姆、联合健康（UnitedHealth）旗下Golden Rule保险公司的理查德·柯林斯（Richard Collins），以及WellPoint的布莱恩·萨西（Brian Sassi）。看起来他们都得到了建议——像很多处在这种境地的公司高管一样——在任何事情上都不要让步。例如，他们不承认听证会的前提，即他们会为了省钱而去寻找踢人出局的方法。
At one point in the hearing, Congressman Stupak pulled out a list of 1,400 medical conditions that, if you have an individual policy with WellPoint insurance, trigger WellPoint to investigate you, looking for some way to cancel your policy.
在听证会的一个时刻，斯图帕克众议员拿出了一份包含1400种医疗状况的名单，如果你有WellPoint保险的个人保单，拥有这些疾病就会触发WellPoint去调查你，寻找某种取消你保单的方法。
Diseases ranging from heart disease and high blood pressure to diabetes and even pregnancy. So what do these conditions have in common that would cause you to investigate patients with these conditions for a possible rescission?
疾病范围从心脏病和高血压到糖尿病甚至怀孕。那么这些状况有什么共同点会导致你调查这些患者以寻求可能的撤销呢？
I would say there's no common theme other than these are conditions that had the applicant disclosed their knowledge of a condition at the time of initial underwriting, we may have taken a different underwriting action.
我会说没有共同主题，只是这些状况如果申请人在初始承保时披露了他们的已知情况，我们可能会采取不同的承保行动。
So in the 1,400 different areas they lie? The applicants lie? Or is it really a cost issue? These are 1,400 expensive areas, aren't they?
所以在这1400个不同的领域他们撒谎？申请人撒谎？还是这真的是成本问题？这些是1400个昂贵的领域，对吧？
Rescission is not about cost.
撤销与成本无关。
According to the subcommittee's investigation, between the years 2003 and 2007, these three companies saved at least $300 million through the use of rescission.
根据小组委员会的调查，在2003年至2007年间，这三家公司通过使用撤销手段至少节省了3亿美元。
The insurance companies' defense of rescission came down, basically, to two ideas. They have to fight fraud if they're going to give decent benefits to everybody else. And rescission is rare.
保险公司对撤销的辩护归根结底是两个想法。如果他们要为其他所有人提供体面的福利，他们就必须打击欺诈。而且撤销是罕见的。
Rescission affects less than one half of 1% of the people we cover.
撤销影响了我们承保人数不到0.5%的人。
During 2008, we rescinded only 1/10 of 1% of individual policies that year.
2008年期间，我们那年撤销的个人保单仅占0.1%。
Our use of rescission is rare. Less than one half of 1% of all individual insurance policies.
我们对撤销的使用是罕见的。占所有个人保险单的不到0.5%。
Here's what those percentages mean in practice. The subcommittee's official report notes that at least 19,776 policies were rescinded between the years 2003 and 2007 by these three companies. They say at least in the report, because UnitedHealth failed to provide data for two years and WellPoint wouldn't provide data from all of its subsidiaries.
这就是这些百分比在实践中的含义。小组委员会的官方报告指出，2003年至2007年间，这三家公司至少撤销了19776份保单。他们在报告中说“至少”，是因为联合健康公司拒绝提供两年的数据，而WellPoint拒绝提供其所有子公司的完整数据。
Toward the end of the three and a half hour hearing, after lawmakers made these three executives sit and listen to people who used to be their own customers, who their own companies had rescinded policies for, even though those people never tried to deceive the insurance companies about their health-- like Robin Beaton, the woman with cancer-- Congressman Bart Stupak boiled everything down to one simple inquiry.
在三个半小时听证会的末尾，在立法者让这三位高管坐下来听取那些曾经是他们自己的客户、被他们自己的公司撤销保单的人的故事之后——即使那些人从来没有试图欺骗保险公司关于他们的健康状况——比如患癌症的罗宾·比顿——巴特·斯图帕克众议员将一切归纳为一个简单的问题。
Let me ask each of our CEOs this question, starting with you, Mr. Hamm. Would you commit today that your company will never rescind another policy unless there was intentional fraudulent misrepresentation in the application?
让我问每一位首席执行官这个问题，从你开始，哈姆先生。你今天是否承诺，除非申请中存在故意的欺诈性失实陈述，否则你们公司绝不会再撤销另一份保单？
I would not commit to that.
我不会承诺这一点。
How about you, Mr. Collins. Would you commit to not to rescind any policy unless there was an intentional fraudulent misrepresentation?
那你呢，柯林斯先生。你承诺除非有故意的欺诈性失实陈述，否则不撤销任何保单吗？
No, sir. We follow the state laws and regulations. And we would not stipulate to that.
不，先生。我们遵循州法律和法规。我们不会同意这一点。
What he's saying is, state laws allow us to do it this way. And we're good with that.
他所说的是，州法律允许我们这样做。而我们对此没问题。
How about you, Mr. Sassi?
那那你呢，萨西先生？
No, I can't commit to that. The intentional standard is not the law of the land in the majority of states.
不，我不能承诺这一点。故意欺诈的标准并不是大多数州的法律。
Can I ask, were you surprised that none of them would commit to this?
我可以问一下，他们中没有人愿意做出承诺，你感到惊讶吗？
Oh no, I wasn't surprised. It doesn't surprise me one, that they would say, well, the law is on our side.
哦，不，我不惊讶。他们会说“法律站在我们这边”，这并不让我感到惊讶。
And when you guys go into these kinds of hearings, do you go into them hoping to get the companies to go on the record and say in a moment like this that they're going to change their policies, or do you just want to get them on the record being obstinate and unsympathetic?
当你们参加这种听证会时，你们是希望让这些公司记录在案，并在这样的时刻说他们会改变政策，还是你们只是想让他们在记录中表现出顽固和毫无同情心的样子？
Well, I guess the answer really is that such a heartless policy of these companies does need to be put on the record and contrasted with the real people who are hurt so badly by those.
好吧，我想答案确实是，这些公司如此冷酷无情的政策确实需要被记录在案，并与被这些政策严重伤害的真实人群形成鲜明对比。
And so the idea is, let's get these guys up here, and get them to show America that they're not going to change unless we push them?
所以想法是，把这些人叫到这里，让他们向美国展示，除非我们推动他们，否则他们是不会改变的？
Exactly.
完全正确。
There came a point where one of the republicans on the panel, Representative Michael Burgess from Texas, who is a doctor, said to the companies, look, I'm on your side. I'd like to help you guys. But I can't help you out if this is how you're going to be.
有一次，委员会的一位共和党人，来自德克萨斯州的迈克尔·伯吉斯（Michael Burgess）众议员，他本身是一名医生，对这些公司说：看，我站在你们这一边。我想帮助你们。但如果你们打算这样，我就帮不了你们了。
And I would urge you to think creatively about this problem, because this is the difficulty that leads us to where we are here today. And I can't help you--
我敦促你们创造性地思考这个问题，因为正是这个困难导致了我们今天在这里。我帮不了你们……
OK, questions or speeches are over.
好了，提问或演讲结束了。
--if you're not willing to move on this issue.
……如果你不愿意在这个问题上有所动摇的话。
Do you feel any sense of hope that the companies will come around and want to work with you? Have you had any moment privately talking to the companies where you have thought, OK, well, maybe?
你感到有任何希望这些公司会回心转意并愿意与你们合作吗？你私下与这些公司交谈时有没有觉得“好吧，也许？”的时候？
No. I think that we just have to make it against the law for them to do it. They've had their way with us for decades. And here we are in this terrible mess, where they want to insure only healthy people. And if you're unlucky enough to get a serious disease or have an accident, then good luck.
不。我认为我们必须让他们的行为非法化。几十年来，他们一直随心所欲。我们现在处于这个可怕的混乱局面中，他们只想为健康的人投保。而如果你不幸得了重病或发生了意外，那祝你好运吧。
Congresswoman Jan Schakowsky of Illinois. She went straight from our interview to a mark up of the House health bill. She told me that she believes that rescission is something that is so hard to defend, something that is so clear cut, that she thinks it's one of the things that Congress is going to be able to outlaw in whatever kind of health reform we end up with.
来自伊利诺伊州的简·沙科夫斯基众议员。她从我们的采访直接去了众议院卫生法案的修订会。她告诉我，她相信撤销行为是如此难以辩护，如此清晰明了，以至于她认为这是国会在我们最终达成的任何医疗改革中能够将其取缔的内容之一。
[MUSIC-"OH MY GOD" BY IDA MARIA]
[音乐——Ida Maria的《Oh My God》]
Act Four, May Be Hazardous to Children.
第四幕，《可能对儿童有害》。
Well, we close today's show with a bit of fine print that codified and made irrevocable some other bigger changes in the life of Susan Burton and her family.
我们以一则小字条文来结束今天的节目，它编纂并使苏珊·伯顿和她家人生活中的其他更大变化变得不可撤销。
When I was 13 my parents got divorced. And my mother, and my sister, and I moved from Michigan to Colorado. Like the pioneers, we settled in Indian territory, on a new street in a subdivision called Arapaho Ridge.
我13岁时父母离婚了。我和妈妈、姐姐搬到了科罗拉多州。像先驱者一样，我们在印第安领地安家，住进了一个叫做阿拉帕霍岭（Arapaho Ridge）的开发区里的一条新街道。
Our house was the color of sand. It had vaulted ceilings, a sunken family room, and the thing we found most offensive, a wet bar. The wet bar, with its ugly brass fittings and diamond paned glass, seemed to symbolize all that was wrong with our newly constructed lives.
我们的房子是沙色的。它有拱形天花板，一个下沉式家庭活动室，以及我们觉得最令人反感的东西——一个湿吧台（wet bar）。那个带丑陋黄铜配件和菱形玻璃的湿吧台，似乎象征着我们新建生活中所有不正确的东西。
We were no longer the perfect family of four, worthy of a tasteful colonial. We were two latch-key kids and a single parent. And we'd been relocated to a tract house.
我们不再是那个完美的四口之家，不再配得上一栋有品位的殖民风格建筑。我们是两个钥匙儿童和一位单身母亲。我们被重新安置到了一栋连排式房屋中。
My mother displaced her anger about this onto the wet bar by refusing to use it for its intended function. The wet bar became our junk drawer. Instead of alcohol she kept files in there-- checkbook registers, coffee maker instructions, and my report cards, which since moving to Colorado, had begun to show lower grades than I'd ever gotten.
我母亲将对这一切的愤怒发泄在湿吧台上，拒绝将其用于原本的功能。湿吧台成了我们的杂物抽屉。她没在那儿放酒精，而是放了文件——支票簿存根、咖啡机说明书，还有我的成绩单，自从搬到科罗拉多后，我的成绩开始显示出我从未有过的低分。
One day I was looking for my standardized test scores. There was no reason except that it was clear to me I was becoming stupid. And I liked to be reminded that I'd once been smart. But instead, I found something unexpected, a big green hanging folder filled with documents labeled divorce. There was a moment of deciding whether or not to open it. Then cautiously, as if I might set off an alarm, I cracked the folder and began to read my parents' divorce agreement.
有一天，我在找我的标准化考试成绩。没有特别的原因，只是因为我很清楚自己正在变笨。我喜欢被提醒我也曾聪明过。但相反，我发现了意想不到的东西：一个贴着“离婚”标签的绿色大吊挂文件夹。有那么一刻，我决定是否要打开它。然后小心翼翼地，好像可能会触发警报一样，我打开文件夹，开始阅读父母的离婚协议。
There was nothing dramatic. No secret half siblings. Not even a custody battle. To anyone else the agreement would have read like what it was, a standard legal document. But my parents' divorce was the biggest thing in my life. I dwelled on it to the point of obsession, to the point of melodrama. As far as I was concerned, it was the most important fact about me. Discovering the agreement was like finding that a new story had somehow been bound into a book I'd already read a thousand times. And like a favorite story, the agreement became something I returned to a couple of times a year all throughout my teens.
没有什么戏剧性的东西。没有秘密的同父异母兄弟姐妹。甚至没有抚养权争夺战。对其他人来说，这份协议读起来就像它本来那样——一份标准法律文件。但父母的离婚是我生活中最大的事情。我沉溺于此，到了强迫症的地步，到了情节剧的地步。对我来说，这是关于我最重要的事情。发现这份协议就像发现一个新故事不知怎么被装订进一本我已经读过一千遍的书里。就像一个最喜欢的故事一样，这份协议成了我在青少年时期每年都要重读几次的东西。
Their names were on the cover page, my mother, the plaintiff, versus my father, the defendant. There was the horrible wrongness of that v that divided them.
他们的名字在封面上，我母亲，原告，对阵我父亲，被告。那个分割他们的“对阵”（v）有着可怕的错误感。
My mother was represented by a lawyer named Bruce Barnhart. To him, these agreements were probably just divorce Mad Libs. He'd sit at his big desk with my mother across from him and fill in blanks. Debts, $2,400 Cascade Country Club. Vehicles, 1986 Volkswagen Jetta. Bank accounts, Merrill Lynch.
我母亲由一位名叫布鲁斯·巴恩哈特（Bruce Barnhart）的律师代理。对他来说，这些协议可能只是离婚“疯狂填词”。他坐在大办公桌前，我母亲坐在他对面，填着空白。债务，2400美元，卡斯卡德乡村俱乐部。车辆，1986年大众捷达。银行账户，美林证券。
But when I read the agreement it didn't seem formulaic. These details were precious to me. And I was grateful they'd been so painstakingly recorded. It made me feel important that somebody took an interest, set down our story like that. Even if the writer was just a lawyer in Grand Rapids, Michigan, who had been paid to do it.
但当我读这份协议时，它看起来并不刻板。这些细节对我来说很珍贵。我很感激它们被如此费心地记录下来。当有人对此产生兴趣，把我们的故事写下来，让我感到自己很重要。即使那个作者只是大急流城的一位律师，拿钱办事。
Sometimes I would copy stuff down from the agreement, as if the information contained in it could get lost just as easily as our family. On one page I found the phone number of a house in which I'd briefly lived with my father when my parents first got separated.
有时我会从协议中抄下一些内容，就好像里面包含的信息很容易丢失，就像我们的家庭一样。在某一页，我找到了父亲和我在父母刚分居时短暂住过的一个房子的电话号码。
My father always had good phone numbers. He got them by telling the operator he had a retarded child who needed something easy to memorize.
我父亲总是有很好的电话号码。他告诉接线员他有一个需要容易记忆的东西的智障孩子，从而得到了它们。
Not easy enough apparently. I'd forgotten this one. I copied the number down on a little Post-it note I saved for years, as if someday they might introduce a calling plan for dialing the past.
显然不够容易。我已经忘了这个了。我把号码抄在一张小便利贴上，保存了好几年，就好像有一天他们可能会推出一种拨打过去时空的套餐。
My parents had joint legal custody, but my mother had physical custody. This was divorced kid rank and serial number. And I was glad to know the exact terms. Child support would be deducted from my father's paychecks and sent directly to my mother through a program called Friend of the Court. For a second I wondered if they were saying my father was a guy who couldn't be trusted to send the money himself. I knew it wasn't true. But it had never occurred to me before.
父母有共同的法律监护权，但我母亲有实际监护权。这就是离婚儿童的等级和序列号。我很高兴知道确切的条款。子女抚养费将从父亲的工资中扣除，并通过一个名为“法院之友”（Friend of the Court）的项目直接寄给我母亲。有一秒钟，我想知道他们是不是在说我父亲是一个不能被信任自己寄钱的人。我知道这不是真的。但之前从未想到过。
Going through the folder always brought a rush of different feelings. There was the fear I'd be caught or that I'd find something disturbing, that my parents had done bad things, or were bad people. But even the smallest thing could move me, something as simple as seeing my parents' initials together on the bottom right-hand corner of each page of a legal document.
翻阅文件夹总会带来一阵不同的情绪。害怕被抓住，或者找到令人不安的东西，比如父母做了坏事，或者他们是坏人。但即使是最微小的事情也能感动我，像在法律文件的每一页右下角看到父母的缩写在一起这样简单的事情。
One afternoon, I found a document that stopped me cold. The hearing that was to set my parents' divorce in motion was only days away. But in this note Mr. Barnhart had written, "Dear Nancy, this will confirm or telephone conference. I have adjourned the hearing date from January 30, 1987 to February 27, 1987. I wish you well in your efforts to resolve your marital difficulties.
一天下午，我发现了一份让我停下来的文件。那份启动父母离婚的听证会只剩下几天了。但在那张纸条上，巴恩哈特先生写道：“亲爱的南希，这将确认或电话会议。我已经将听证会日期从1987年1月30日推迟到1987年2月27日。祝你在解决婚姻困难方面一切顺利。”
I sat before the wet bar for a beat. I was a scholar of my parents' divorce who had just found the primary document of my dreams. Here was a suggestion that my parents had tried to stay together. I ached that they hadn't been able to reconcile.
我在湿吧台前坐了一会儿。我是父母离婚的学者，刚刚找到了我梦寐以求的主要文件。这里暗示父母曾尝试维持婚姻。他们没能和解，我感到心痛。
It has been almost 20 years since I lived in that house. And I haven't looked at the agreement since, until recently. I asked my mother for the folder. And after she gave it to me, it took me a couple of days to open it. I was worried that the agreement wouldn't give me the same feeling. Maybe the story of my family's disintegration had lost its hold over me. It was possible that, like the music of Bon Jovi, I'd be mystified by its former appeal. But the agreement held up better than I'd expected.
我离开那个房子已经快20年了。从那以后我没再看过这份协议，直到最近。我向母亲要了那个文件夹。在她给我之后，我花了两天才打开它。我担心协议不会给我同样的感觉。也许家庭解体的故事已经不再吸引我了。可能就像邦·乔维（Bon Jovi）的音乐一样，我会对它以前的吸引力感到困惑。但这份协议比我预期的要耐看。
I'd forgotten that a divorce agreement is like a murder mystery, where the murder happens on the first page. The opening language is brutal. "There has been a breakdown in the marriage relationship to the extent that the objects of matrimony have been destroyed. And there remains no reasonable likelihood that the marriage can be preserved. Now therefore, it is ordered and adjudged that this marriage is hereby dissolved."
我忘了离婚协议就像谋杀谜题，谋杀发生在第一页。开头的语言是残酷的。“婚姻关系已破裂，以至于婚姻的目的已被摧毁。且婚姻已无合理的保存可能性。因此，特此下令并判决该婚姻在此解散。”
I felt the same way reading these words at my desk as an adult as I had on the floor at 14. Back then these words knocked the wind out of me. To me this wasn't legalese. I wasn't old enough ever to have signed a contract for a rental or to have read the terms and conditions of a credit card agreement. To me this was the language of proclamations and founding documents. It was commensurate with my experience of my parents' divorce as an event that had changed the world. The weight I felt inside was matched by the weight of these words.
作为一个成年人，我在桌前读这些话时的感觉和14岁时在地板上读时一样。那时，这些话让我喘不过气来。对我来说，这不是法律用语。我还不够大，没签过租房合同，也没读过信用卡协议的条款。对我来说，这是宣言和立国文件的语言。这与我作为父母离婚这件事改变世界的经历相称。我内心的分量与这些文字的分量相吻合。
At the end of those summer afternoons, I'd return the divorce agreement to the wet bar as reverently as if I were replacing the Constitution in its marble shrine.
在那些夏日的下午结束时，我会把离婚协议放回湿吧台，就像在把宪法放回大理石神龛一样虔诚。
Susan Burton lives in New York.
苏珊·伯顿住在纽约。
Well our program was produced today by Sean Cole and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Aaron Scott. Our music consultant each week is Jessica Hopper.
我们的节目今天由肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、萨拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、阿莉莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克参与。资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。制作协助来自亚伦·斯科特（Aaron Scott）。我们每周的音乐顾问是杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Support for This American Life it provided by Fox Searchlight Pictures, presenting the new comedy 500 Days of Summer featuring 500 days of rooftop parties, broken hearts, kissing in the copy room, starring Joseph Gordon Levitt and Zooey Deschanel. Now playing in select theaters.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。对《美国生活》的支持由福克斯探照灯影业（Fox Searchlight Pictures）提供，呈现新喜剧《500天》，展现500天的屋顶派对、破碎的心、复印室里的亲吻，主演约瑟夫·高登-莱维特（Joseph Gordon Levitt）和佐伊·丹斯切尔（Zooey Deschanel）。现已在部分影院上映。
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss Mr. Torey Malatia, who follows me around the office trying to always get me to say the letter L, which he knows I can't say. He especially loves it when I say Lillian Hellman.
WBEZ电台对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他一直在办公室里跟着我，试图让我说出字母L，他知道我发不出那个音。他尤其喜欢我说“莉莲·海尔曼”（Lillian Hellman）的时候。
Go on, say it. Say it. Say it.
说出来。快，说出来。说出来。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。